WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi, there.
It's time to start writing
applications for Android Auto.
I'm Wayne Piekarski from Google.
And today, I'm going
to show you how easy it
is to extend your
existing messaging
application to
support Android Auto.
The Android Auto software
runs on your phone
and is responsible for drawing
the user interface that
appears on the
vehicle's display here.
So the phone connects to
the vehicle via USB cable.
And if you want to learn
more about how this works,
you should check out our
"Introduction to Android Auto"
DevByte.
Android Auto provides
extensions that
allow you to easily integrate
it with your existing messaging
application.
These extensions allow
you to use a voice control
interface optimized
for use in a car.
You can use voice controls to
reply to message notifications
without having to
type on your phone.
This is great, because
the user's driving a car,
and they need
minimal distractions,
and they need to keep
their eyes on the road.
And best of all,
Android Auto takes
care of all the hard parts of
speech recognition for you.
You just need to add a
few extra lines of code.
Oh, look.
Here's a message from
my colleague Brian.
Let's see what he has to say.
[BING]
ANDROID: Here's the message.
"You're late for the studio."
[BING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Reply to message.
ANDROID: Say your message.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I'll be
there in five minutes, Brian.
ANDROID: Here's your message.
"I'll be there in
five minutes, Brian."
Do you want to send it?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yes.
ANDROID: Sending message.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: All right.
Well, let's head
off to the studio.
Right now, your existing
messaging application
will use notification
objects to tell the user
when a message has arrived.
So the notification is going to
contain the text of the message
and providing an intent to
run when the notification is
selected on the user's phone.
So this is what
you already have.
Now, what I'm going
to show you now
is how to add some simple
notification extensions
to your notification objects to
get Android Auto functionality.
To enable the ability to reply
to messages from the car,
the first thing
you need to do is
to create a
remoteInput instance.
And this is going to be
responsible for receiving
and processing audio
input from Android Auto.
A speech recognizer is
used on the spoken audio,
and the notification
system will then
deliver this as a plain string
to an intent that we provide.
If you've ever done any
Android Wear extensions before,
you'll notice this
is very similar.
Next, we need to
provide to Android Auto
the contents of any
unread messages,
so that it can read
them out to the user
and possibly take a reply back.
To do this, you firstly create
a new UnreadConversation object
from the CarExtender class
and provide four pieces
of information-- the
name of the person
who sent the message,
a time stamp, an intent
to indicate when
a message is read,
and a reply action using
the previous remote input.
Your messaging
application will right now
contain an array or a
list of existing messages.
And you'll write
a full loop that
traverses through every
unread message from the sender
and add them to this
UnreadConversation object.
Now you need to take your
existing notification code
and add the CarExtender and
UnreadConversation objects,
and then issue the notification
as you would have done before.
And that's basically
it from the Java side.
So you can take
your existing code,
and by adding a few
extra lines, you
get Android Auto
functionality as well.
So to finish up,
your application
needs to tell Android Auto
that it supports notifications
via CarExtender.
So to do this, you will need to
set up your AndroidManifest.xml
to reference an XML file
with an automotiveApp
tag along with a
notification attribute.
Now, to test your
application, we
provide a messaging
simulator that
looks very similar to
the car experience.
So you can run the
simulator on your phone
or in the Android
emulator to test
that you're using
the API correctly.
It captures the notifications
and supports the CarExtender
extensions.
And this is great for
testing at your desk
while you're doing
the development cycle.
As you can see, the
fundamentals of your application
remain the same here, but
you added some very simple
extensions to your
notification objects
to get Android Auto features.
This means it'll be really
easy to extend your existing
messaging application and
to get it out to your users.
And what's great about
this is that the same style
of extensions used in Android
Auto are used for Android Wear
as well, which shows you
how extendable the Android
notification system is and
how easy it is to get started.
So let's get back out to
the car and finish up.
You can find out more about
Android Auto by visiting
the documentation site and also
joining the Google+ community,
where you can share your
ideas with everybody else.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, and thanks
very much for joining me.
I'll see you next time.
Navigate to the Googleplex.
[BING]